fue su promesa bandera durante la
campaña y ahora su primera victoria
legislativa tras un largo debate
funcionado / dio luz verde al ambicioso
plan de ayudas por 1,9 millones de
dólares de joe biden menor al de 22
billones de dólares aprobado en un
primer paquete de estímulos hace un año
y mayor al de 900 mil millones
entregados en diciembre de slice en el
soft esta nación ha sufrido mucho por
demasiado tiempo y todo lo que incluye
este paquete está diseñado para aliviar
el sufrimiento y para enfrentar las
necesidades más urgentes de la nación y
ponernos en una posición de prevalecer
el paquete comprende unos 400.000
millones en pagos únicos de 1400 dólares
a cada familia que genere ingresos
anuales menores a 80 mil dólares también
extiende los 300 dólares semanales en
beneficios de desempleo extendidos para
9.5 millones de desempleados hasta el
verano y otorga 350 mil millones en
ayuda a los gobiernos estatales también
incluye recursos para la fabricación y
distribución de vacunas el partido
republicano que esperaba una ronda de
ayudas mucho menor
es bueno introducir una larga lista de
enmiendas a la iniciativa el 90% de lo
que hay en este proyecto de ley no tiene
nada que ver con kobe es una lista de
deseos liberal esta es una oportunidad
para gastar dinero en cosas no
relacionadas con kobe y los demócratas
lo están haciendo porque pueden el
proyecto de ley pasará a la cámara de
representantes el martes y yo bailé en
espera tenerlo en su escritorio la
próxima semana